[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to once again
be discussing
the famed hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry
more specifically i'm going to be
addressing a lingering question
that i'm sure has come across the minds
of fans at one point or another
is there a hogwarts graduation ceremony
i know that a few of you have requested
this video in the comments
so here you go graduation ceremonies are
right of passage
and they exist at nearly every level of
academic institution
whether it's finishing primary school or
finally graduating from university
a graduation is a way to celebrate
academic achievement
a way for students to be praised for
their accomplishments
these types of ceremonies usually
involve the handing off of a diploma
or degree an accreditation of some sort
as a way of indicating that the student
met all the necessary requirements to
graduate
so as hogwarts operates just like any
other institution
with years of progression classes
professors and schedules
then in theory it should have a
graduation ceremony
right well the truth is that the
ceremony was omitted from the harry
potter story
because rowling felt that the inclusion
of the ceremony would have been an
absurd anti-climax
it also wouldn't have really made much
sense to include the graduation as harry
ron and hermione
skipped their seventh year and
technically didn't meet the requirements
to graduate
that same year i can't quite imagine the
film
book ending the graduation ceremony that
failed to include the very trio
that saved the wizarding world from
voldemort that would be quite an
injustice
however it turns out that just because
graduation was omitted from the books
films it doesn't mean that it doesn't
exist
in fact jk rowling confirmed the
existence of the hogwarts graduation
ceremony
in an interview now you know what i'm
curious about now
is that one of the neatest things about
the hogwarts tradition is the entrance
ceremony
from the whole riding the boats to the
castle to the sorting ceremony
what kind of traditions are there for
graduation and leaving hogwarts
do you know i'm really glad you asked
that because i felt a huge sadness
that i wouldn't write a graduation scene
i really
during the final book kept thinking it
would have been
it felt sad that the book wasn't going
to end with that feast scene
the graduation scene but it couldn't it
just
couldn't that's not the way it could
have ended it would have felt far too
trite
and a lot of people felt the epilogue
was too sentimental i think to have a
graduation scene on top of what just
happened
would have been absurd anti-climax did
you have ideas for kinds of traditions
they would do
like ride the boats back out of hogwarts
oh yeah
definitely the boats would have been the
most poetic and beautiful way for them
to leave
and symbolic in that they harry would
have seen the thestrals again
you know what i mean it would have been
a return to innocence really
and passage of water is so symbolic in
history of magic
so yeah i think it would have been great
and there you have it
the hogwarts graduation ceremony would
be comprised of graduating students
floating away from the school on the
very enchanted boats that brought them
there
though not explicitly stated by rowling
i would imagine that in addition to this
there would have been some sort of
ceremony in the great hall perhaps akin
to the announcement of the winners of
the house cup
we also mustn't forget the feast oh the
delicious feast
that's it for today's video what did you
imagine the hogwarts graduation was like
did you know that there was one let me
know in the comment section below
before i end the video with a closing
quote i just want to let you all know
about a new aspect of the videos moving
forward
i've typically ended videos with quotes
that i felt were powerful or
particularly resonated with me
however moving forward i'm going to
attempt to close each video
with a new and different quote from the
series i thought it could be fun for you
guys to try and identify who said the
quote by leaving a comment on the video
until next time differences of habits
and language
are nothing at all if our aims are
identical their hearts
are open
you